survoler la terre
ce doit être l'une des plus
merveilleuses expériences à vivre
de là haut non seulement la vue est
imprenable mais surtout dans la station
spatiale internationale
on a la chance d'expérimenter cette
sensation unique qu'est la pesanteur
veritas superbe vidéo à ce sujet en fait
les astronautes ne sont qu'à quelques
centaines de kilomètres au-dessus de la
terre par opposition la lune est à des
centaines de milliers de kilomètres
comparé à la lune les astronautes sont
donc collé à la surface de la terre mais
si la gravité de la terre est
suffisamment grande pour faire tourner
la lune pourquoi n'agir est elle pas sur
les astronautes aussi pourquoi les
astronautes n'aurait-il pas de poids
pourquoi serait-il en apesanteur
pourquoi la gravité n'est gyr est elle
pas sur eux
comme vous l'avez deviné si la gravité
de la terre ail et sur la lune elle agit
bien sûr sur les astronautes aussi en
fait la force de gravité sur les
astronautes est à peu près la même que
sur nous sur terre du coup les
astronautes ont un poids et son tronc
pesanteur ils ne sont pas en apesanteur
mais c'est étrange tout ça
comment peuvent-elles se sentir en
apesanteur s'ils ne sont pas en
apesanteur
comment peuvent ils subirent la gravité
sans la sentir
et bien ça c'est une question
incroyablement profonde et merveilleuse
qui conduisit albert einstein à la
pensée la plus heureuse de sa vie mais
avant de vous parler d'einstein
je vais vous donner l'explication
newtonienne de ce sentiment d'apple en
heure qui est celle donnée par bruce sur
y penser et par jamais deux sans trois
dans mes commentaires
d'après la loi de la chute des corps de
galilée
l'astronaute et la station spatiale de
tombes tous deux aussi vite
du coup pour l'astronaute la station
spatiale ne bouge pas or qui ne voit que
la station spatiale
il a donc l'impression de flotter par
rapport à tous ceux qui l'entourent donc
pour newton
l'astronaute n'est pas en apesanteur il
a un poids il est temps pesanteur mais
son environnement immédiat l'induit en
erreur
il fait croire que la gravité n'agit pas
sur lui alors oui ça marche comme
explication mais c'est pas super élégant
et puis ça soulève d'autres questions
pourquoi est-ce que l'astronaute
tomberait aussi vite que la station
spatiale et bien si on en croit newton
cela ne peut être le cas que si l'on
suppose l'intrigante égalité entre la
masse inertielle et la masse
gravitationnelle la masse inertielle et
celle qui intervient dans le principe
fondamental de la dynamique qui dit
qu'il faut plus de force pour modifier
le mouvement des objets avec une plus
grande masse inertielle la masse
gravitationnelle quant à elle est celle
qui intervient dans la loi de la
gravitation de newton qui dit que les
objets avec une plus grande masse
gravitationnelle possède une plus grande
force d'attraction gravitationnelle ces
deux masses sont des concepts très
différentes
pourtant newton affirma qu'elle se
devait d'être égal mais pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi se demandant pourquoi
est-ce que la gravité sur intel ni
dictée par neuer 6
selon la légende einstein se baladait un
jour dans les rue de pernes
quand il vit un homme tombé du haut
d'une tour einstein se précipita vers
l'homme qui hurlait de douleur il lui
demande à monsieur monsieur monsieur
vous avez senti la gravité en tombant
alors cette histoire est sans doute
fausse néanmoins einstein fut tout à
coup convaincu que l'homme en chute
libre ne peut pas sentir son poids comme
la fnau et einstein trouva une nouvelle
explication absolument révolutionnaire à
ceux ci nomme en chute libre comme
l'astronaute là haut ne sont pas leur
poids
non pas parce qu'ils sont induits en
erreur par leur environnement immédiat
ils ne sentent pas leur poids car ils
n'ont pas de poids le poids n'existe
purement et simplement pas et ça c'est
parce que la gravité n'est pas une force
la gravité n'est pas n'est pas une force
de gravité n'est pas une force la
gravité n'est pas une force la gravité
n'est pas une force la gravité n'est pas
une force la gravité n'est pas une force
a selon ses propres dires ce fut l'idée
la plus heureuse d'einstein la qualité
les pèse une porsche
ok la gravité n'est pas une force mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que voulait
dire einstein quand il disait que la
gravité n'est pas une force est bien
pour comprendre ce que voulait dire
einstein il nous faut vivre et respirer
la physique comme le faisait einstein
que sentez-vous à l'instant présent
quelles sont les forces physiques que
vous sentez agir sur vous
et bien si j'y réfléchis vraiment tout
ce que je ressens c'est quelque chose au
niveau de mes pieds quelque chose qui
qui semble pousser mes pieds qui semble
pousser mes pieds vers le haut et bien
selon einstein
cette force qui pousse mes pieds vers le
haut fait accélérer mon corps vers le
haut se passe quelque chose de similaire
dans un ascenseur quand l'ascenseur
accélère vers le bas je me sens tout à
coup plus léger en fait si je mesurais
mon poids dans l'ascenseur avec une
balance tu vois je trouverai un poids
plus léger
alors newton dirais que c'est parce que
je fais mal ma mesure mais pas pour
einstein pour einstein mme à mesure de
mon poids dans l'ascenseur est
fondamentalement juste mon poids dans
l'ascenseur est vraiment plus faibles
car la gravité dans l'ascenseur est plus
faible aussi si ça c'est pas étrange la
gravité dans l'ascenseur est déterminé
par l'accélération de l'ascenseur en
fait quand l'ascenseur est en chute
libre
c'est à dire quand il accélère à dix
mètres par seconde carré par rapport au
sol la gravité dans l'ascenseur
disparaît purement et simplement dans ce
cas mon poids mesuré dans l'ascenseur
serait nul n'aurait pas de poids je
serai
l'auteur plus généralement la pensée la
plus heureuse d'einstein plus de
comprendre que la gravité et
l'accélération ne sont que les faces
opposées d'une même pièce c'est ce qu'a
rappelé le principe d'équivalence et
c'est l'une des plus heureuses penser
que quiconque est jamais c'est d'un
génie et platon ainsi en utilisant son
principe d'équivalence einstein apporta
un éclairage nouveau
la mystérieuse voix de la chute des
corps de galilée vous vous souvenez
galilée avait prouvé qu'ils étaient
inconsistants de penser que les objets
plus lourd tombe plus vite
nul doute c'était brillant vraiment
brillant mais de là à conclure que tous
les objets tombent aussi vite il y avait
encore un grand pas à faire l'argument
de calais n'était ni conclusive nous
instructif en titane rétorqua alors que
si l'on a du mal à comprendre la chute
d'objets c'est parce qu'on étudie
constamment dans le référentiel du sol
or le sol dit il n'est pas un
référentiel naturel en somme technique
ce n'est pas un référentiel galiléen le
sol accélère constamment vers le haut
poussé par la pression des couches
inférieures les temps fait beaucoup plus
naturelle dit einstein d'étudier la
chute des objets dans le référentiel des
objets en chu cas dans le vide ces
objets ne sont sous l'action d'aucune
force même pas la gravité car la gravité
n'est pas une force et donc leurs
référentiels et galiléen et dans ce
référentiel ces objets qui ne subissent
aucune force sont immobiles et c'est le
seul qui accélère vers le haut dans ce
point de vue la loi de la chute des
corps de galilée devient tout à coup une
évidence les objets atteignent le sol en
même temps car aucun de ces objets de
bouche dans le référentiel commun et
c'est le seul qui accélère et les
atteindre à tous en même temps quelle
résonance fantastique
au bout du compte bien plus que les
observations expérimentales que je ne
peux pas répéter moi même c'est cette
explication absolument
de la mystérieuse loi de la chute des
corps de galilée qui me donne envie de
croire en achetant allait y aller
c'est en 1907 kansteiner eu cette pensée
la plus heureuse de sa vie c'était une
pensée incroyable une pensée formidable
mais ce n'était qu'une pensée pour
transformer cette pensée en une théorie
crédible de la physique
einstein savait qu'il allait devoir
réécrire complètement la théorie de la
mécanique de newton
c'était incroyablement ambitieux
d'autant qu'anne stein était alors qu'un
inconnu
d'ailleurs le grand max planck conseilla
un design de renoncer à sa quête d'une
théorie de la gravité la gravité lui
semblait bien trop compliqué et aussi
brillante que fussent la poncer
bernstein
ce n'était qu'un point de départ pour
aller plus loin einstein allait devoir
maîtriser le calcul t'en sors yale et la
géométrie des espaces courbe l'ailé
devoir être plus créatif que tous les
savants avant lui il allait devoir être
plus malin que tous les génies de son
temps en bref il allait devoir devenir
le plus grand scientifique de l'histoire
einstein et est il à la hauteur de ses
ambitions
la dernière fois on a parlé de la
manière dont newton a découvert les lois
de la gravité et le double fait
remarquer que newton n'a pas vraiment
inventé la dérive et mais plutôt des
fluxion est en effet newton avait un
langage très peu algébrique tout cas
très éloigné de celui qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui
en fait le calcul intégral édifiant
celle que l'on en apprend aujourd'hui à
l'école et celui de leibniz et dans
l'histoire des sciences est une énorme
controverse entre newtown et l'avenir
pour savoir lequel des deux a vraiment
inventé la dérive et donc si je la fais
courte nous donner le premier à avoir
pensé à cet objet il en a donné une
interprétation géométrique mais ce qu'a
fait la miss est absolument monumental
puisqu'il a simplifié clarifier toute
cette théorie et puis surtout il lui a
donné cette notation algérie qui nous
ait su utile aujourd'hui ans pour finir
vraiment cette histoire florent je vous
dise quelle une énorme rivalité à
l'époque entre newtown et la miss qui
était une rivalité nationale entre
l'angleterre et l'allemagne
et chacun des pays défendent est en gros
sont scientifiques mais au final la plus
importante autorité scientifique de
l'époque était la rue lindsay duchesne
de londres en angleterre et le président
de cette fois une situation n'était
autre que newton humaine du coup la
vologne l'institution qui a été l'
autorité scientifique qui allait statuer
sur les mérites et des uns des autres
bizarrement a rédigé un rapport écrit
par un certain newton qui disait que
newton était le seul et unique créateur
de cette théorie de du calcul
différentiel et intégral n'étonne c'est
un petit peu un [ __ ] comme j'en ai
déjà un petit peu parlé dans ma vidéo
c'est pas un personnage que j'aimerais
rencontrer personnellement je pense
qu'il nous ferait bien flipper newton
je vous rappelle qu' un défilé en cours
que j'ai vu poser dans l'épisode
précédent il posait la question qu'est
ce qui se passe si on accélère
constamment à ce qu'on finit par
dépasser la vitesse de la lumière et
vous voyez que cette question est ultra
pertinente dans le cadre du sol puisque
le sol est en accélération constante
vers le haut et du coup est-ce qu'on
finit par dépasser la vitesse de la
lumière en étant au niveau du sol
on espère que ça va donner un peu de
grain à moudre à votre moulin je reviens
aussi enfin sur la question d'olive et
de ricard de l'épisode 14 sur le
centrisme qui se demandait s'il était
possible de mesurer sur terre le fait
que la terre tourne autour du soleil et
dans les commentaires de l'épisode 15 je
vous avais dit que pour faire cette
année s'il fallait absolument prendre en
compte la force de gravité du soleil sur
nous
et au parti qu est ce qu il faut
comparer c'est le cas où la terre tourne
toujours sur l'équerré force de gravité
du soleil sur la terre versus le cas où
la terre est immobile et qui n'ont pas
de gravité est en fait cette question
elle est extrêmement similaires c'est
quasiment la même quelle question de
savoir si les astronautes sont en
apesanteur ou plutôt si bush par rapport
à la station spatiale invite vraiment
résoudre ce problème à la main faire des
calculs il lui donnait un peu un sketch
de la preuve du fait qu'en fait les deux
cas sont indiscernables on ne peut pas
vraiment distinguer le fait que la terre
est immobile versus la terre tourne
autour du soleil avec une forte gravité
par pour résoudre ça vous pouvez vous
placer dans un référentiel géocentrique
1 où la terre est au centre et vous fait
le bilan des forces appliquer la loi de
newton qui s'applique encore dans ce
référentiel même si les noms de gally 20
à condition d'ajouter dans les forces
la force d'inertie d'entraînement et là
vous avez donc deux forces en plus sa
force d'inertie l'entraînement et la
force de gravité du soleil sur la terre
vous voyez que ces deux forces à nu et
en utilisant le fait que la masse
gravitationnelle est égale hamas
inertielle vous concluez que pour
n'importe quel objet sur terre ces deux
forces là vont toujours s'annuler du
coup le bilan des forces d'un côté vers
suspens on est exactement le même
et en particulier tous les calculs que
vous ferez au niveau de terre sont
identiques à ceux que vous feriez si
vous supposiez que le référentiel
géocentrique et galileo et ça c'est
vraiment le message qu redemption c'est
le truc vraiment magique dans la théorie
d'einstein ou deux lieues d'imaginer
qu'il ya des forces et que tous ces nuls
et que finalement tout marche toi c'est
un peu magique après beaucoup de calculs
einstein directement la gravité n'est
pas une force arrêtez de vous embêter à
l'étude avec ses calculs temps ils sont
faux ce qui compte c'est que la terre
est immobile et la terre est immobile
parce qu'il n'y a aucune force qui agit
sur elle même pas la gravité puisque la
gravité n'est pas une force de
vacanciers déjà au centre et qui est un
référentiel guérir tout comme le
référentiel de la station spatiale est
un référentiel eagles ayant ça c'est
vraiment toute la magie de la théorie
d'einstein c'est juste tellement beau et
qui c'est ultra convaincant à c'est pour
ça que j'y crois c'est le must c'est ça
aussi qui fait que la théorie est jamais
aussi belle
je vous invite vraiment à y réfléchir
alors il ya quand même un petit mensonge
lorsque j'ai dit si vous faites les
calculs vraiment exact vous avez vous
rendre compte en fait le meilleur des
forces si vous êtes sûr terme du côté du
soleil et pas le même que si vous êtes
sur terre mais de l'autre côté du soleil
d'une petite différence entre la terre
immobile
dire tout est dans tout cela est dû au
fait que la terre s'étend spatialement
et ça ça veut dire que l'accélération du
champ de plants tordu au soleil en
certains points est différent dans
d'autres points
et ça ça va créer des déformations de la
terre ou en tout cas de trucs qui sont
sur terre c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet
des marées
parce qu en particulier celles explique
les marais en fait les marais sont
causés par les lunes et plus exactement
par les variations du champ de
pesanteurs de la lune sur la terre en
fait l'explication des marais est bien
plus compliqué que ça comme le montre
cette vidéo de pie v spéciale était en
fait tout ce que j'avais appris sur les
marais et très probablement faux bond en
voir s'il fait très vite car non pas
kelly a démarré ce n'est pas parce que
l'eau est attirée sur les bords à cause
du gradient du chanteur mais c'est parce
que elle est attirée vers le centre du
coup c'est comme si on pressait sur la
terre lorsqu'on presse sur la terre
l'eau a tendance à s'éloigner comme
lorsqu'on on pressent un citron l'eau va
partir sur les côtés et c'est pour ça
qu'il est mort il à ce niveau là vous
devriez me demander que c'est facile en
physique
einstein yens est-ce qu'on a encore ses
c'est gras dian du champ de pesanteur en
physique einstein yens et réponse est
clairement non la gravité du pas une
force du coup ni pourrait avoir de
création de forces sur terre et du coup
la grande question c'est est-ce qu'il ya
encore démarré en physique and stones
yens et là la réponse est pour la
prochaine fois et j'espère que vous avez
aimé cette vidéo et que l'idée la plus
heureuse d'einstein a suscité quelques
idées au moins un peu heureuse on
plaisante dans vos cerveaux si ce n'est
pas le cas et je compte le choix tout à
fait que je ne sois pas le cas c'est
parce que je ne vais pas encore assez
bien expliqué il ya eu beaucoup
d'informations dans cette vidéo donc je
vous invite aussi à la revoir plusieurs
fois et si vous voulez une autre source
ou le conseille très fortement celle de
psp stan bon elle est en anglais mais il
se trouve que ce principe d'équivalence
d'einstein cette idée sur laquelle le
seul accélère vers le haut et un fou
qu'il est très très très peu expliquée
jeu
je serais très très très peu de sources
qu'il expliquait entre qui explique les
liens y compris dans des cours de
soirées dites générales que cosmologie
cette idée absolument géniale qui est
vraiment lié la chaîne sur laquelle le
sol accélère vers le haut
n'apparaît pas ou n'est pas vraiment
expliqué et je trouve ça vraiment
dommage parce que personnellement c'est
la cud est la plus heureuse que jamais
découverte
également en tout cas je vous assure que
j'y ai réfléchi pendant des mois et des
mois mais c'est juste un qualcomm le sol
accélère vers le haut et tout dans notre
monde quotidien s'explique par le fait
que le sol accélère vers le haut et en
gros le ce qu'on appelle le poids ou
forcés vérité dans fait qu'on force
d'inertie d'entraînement du fait de
cette extraction
je vous invite vraiment y réfléchir
c'est juste ou merveilleux moi ça m'a
rendu heureux pendant plusieurs mois dit
penser qu c'est vraiment trop beau mais
c'est quelque chose aussi qui devrait
soulever énormément de questions et
j'attends vos questions dans les
commentaires qui vont nous permettre
d'avancer et de parler dans l'épisode
suivant de la relativité générale en
tant que tel du coup je vous conseille
vraiment de veut pas rater le prochain
épisode pour ça vous pouvez vous abonner
à cinq forums
si vous avez aimé cet épisode n'hésitez
pas à liker à le commenter à le partager
et pour le coup j'espère vraiment que je
vous ferai la prochaine for you tube
kristen stewart du prochain